how much did you miss playing at Bankers
Life Fieldhouse in front of these fans I
was amazing amazing words can't describe
it man it's uh it's been a hard hard
year a really tough year but God is good
god is good I have a great family here
my teammates are amazing
[Applause]
you're one for seven down three there's
a timeout called I know it's silly to
ask you how did you have the confidence
but as you walk back out on the court
did you feel like it was meant to be for
you to take that shot to put this game
into overtime and as I have you answered
that question let's look back at the
monitor and tell me what you saw on that
final play I just shot a man I just shot
it man Mamba mentality
I'm a mentality I'm a mentality man
that's what cold Gigi autumn people I
was on the helicopter that's what I've
been it's been a tough year man but
tough times don't last tough people do I
work so hard man
thankful for my friends this this state
these people my family my teammates
[Music]
is an emotional night as one that fans
have been looking forward to but you had
been looking forward to as well as I get
one final thought you get ready to walk
out of here and I know your connection
to the fans of something special you've
said the last month or two how much it's
meant their support how much you've
heard from them on social media and
every time you go anywhere can you
describe the feelings you have for this
city and these fans I'm just a full
breath I'm just a full
got old
thank you very much the guys in motion
this is a hard thing to do
he's been a full year trying to get it
together
and he had